the most important thing you have to
remember is that every time you transfer
data no matter how small the radio could
stay powered up for nearly half a minute
so every decision you make should be
based on minimizing the number of times
that this happens but of course there's
a balance here you want to download all
the data a user is likely to need for
the current session in a single burst
over a single connection at full
capacity but of course you don't just
want to pull down everything wasting
battery power and bandwidth downloading
data that's never going to be used now I
could go on for hours on this topic but
Dan's getting impatient and you can
learn the details on how to implement
each of these best practices including
prefetching batching and bundling baring
your update frequency and minimizing
your payloads by watching the series of
dev byte videos or reading the developer
guides link to in the instructor notes
below now before I leave it to Dan to
show you how to implement a sync adapter
for sunshine that takes advantage of a
lot of the best practices I just
described let's consider what the best
practice would be if you were building
something like a newsreader and how much
data should you download when the app is
first started just the front page of
headlines all the stories and images
linked to from that front page every
story available but none of the images
or every story and every image currently
available